oh that was just uh painful i captioned
that when memes come true
you know i have to hand it to the kids
though the students who are standing
there sitting there listening to because
the kids you know they're so candid if
they're allowed to speak their thoughts
you know what they're thinking they're
looking at her thinking why are you so
awkward
because that's probably the most awkward
presentation that
i've ever seen
i believe those were child actors we
have some reporting on that i'm not
kidding governor i believe they may have
been child actors not even real kids but
it is clear that
this gets this gets better and better as
the hours go by i mean she needs help
she's not done a great job with her
border assignment clearly she pretty
much got out of dodge after afghanistan
so she's looking for stuff to do can't
find anything good to tackle here
on this green earth so you know just got
to go to a galaxy far far away oh
uh yeah you know those clips really are
painful to watch and this is a a tough
interview to do because i have some
people in the studio who are laughing so
hard that they're kind of getting me off
track right now because they saw the
clip but um
yeah
awkward videos that were presented
at least the media didn't um you know
hide that one you guys at least found it
and ran it but
same with president biden's videos
watching him try to speak and read the
teleprompter i get cold sweat it's
difficult for me to watch i think in his
case it's elder abuse where they
trot him on out there and expect him to
be um articulate about anything it's um
it's tough to watch well he's delegating
everything first he sends kamala down to
central america that didn't work and now
he's sending his ag his dhs secretary is
secretary of state he's sending all of
his cabinet down to mexico to figure
that out because kamal has basically
like you know washed her hands of it i
don't know what's going to happen it's
only going to get worse but it's
interesting that today hillary
popped out of the woodwork to remind us
that you know what she's still here
watch
any interest at all in getting back into
the game of politics i will never be out
of the game of politics i'm not going to
be running for anything but i really
feel amy and i know
george was interviewing adam schiff
before
i really feel like our democracy is at
stake and there's many reasons for that
i really am worried about what's
happening at home and around the world
so i'm never going to get out of uh you
know being
involved worried and hopefully trying to
help in some way
she's never going to get out of politics
that sounds like a threat
well this just seems to be a day where
lots of the old husbands are being
trotted out to give some comments that's
kind of ironic today you know what
let me address though the good point you
were making about kamala kamala kamala
uh being sent to the border but not
doing a doggone thing i think i don't
know she didn't show up in the right
place anyway but then uh the president
biden now sending the rest of the team
down to the border trying to figure it
out what's to figure out jesse what else
to figure out trump had the answer any
reasonable common sense constitutional
conservative has the answer and that's
you build the wall you pay attention to
what's going on at the border and um you
go from there what what is so difficult
about that what am i missing
it's not difficult and uh he's making it
difficult and and that's the problem and
i think the fact that hillary's popping
up and saying hey america i'm still here
signals that a lot of folks inside the
democrat party know that joe's going to
be a one-termer they know kamal is
plotting to be the nominee no one thinks
kamala can can win again in 2024. so
hillary is like saying i'm still here
don't forget about me i got more votes
in the popular vote than donald trump
hey hey guys
uh wouldn't surprise me you know i
wouldn't bet against that at all that uh
hillary jumps back in there and remember
what happened to kamala during the
primary she didn't go anywhere you know
that even the democrats within her own
party they weren't going to nominate her
they weren't elevating her into any
any kind of position and uh you know i
think she checked a lot of boxes for the
need there on the ticket and that's why
she is there today she sure did and i
think she should focus on solving
problems here on earth
before she starts focusing on outer
space thank you so much governor palin
always enjoy having you on hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else